good evening
good evening
good evening my name is john ending and
i am a third year law student here at
yale law school and i would like to
welcome you to the veritas forum
at yale
we're here tonight to have a
conversation about an issue that has
proved to be both divisive and
difficult to understand
it is also we believe extraordinarily
timely and relevant
both to this campus and also our nation
i know that all of us have been troubled
in one way or another following the
deaths of eric garner
michael brown
tamir rice and others
and many of you like me don't know how
to respond
so the question for which we're gathered
tonight then is how we might respond to
the complex issue of racial and
injustice and inequality
how have politics faith and the law
contributed to the problem and how can
they also aid in the solution
the veritas forum at yale is sponsored
by the black law students association
kai alpha
the council of latin american and
iberian studies
the graduate and professional school
senate
graduate student life
living water the rivendell institute
yale faith in action yale graduate
christian fellowship
yale health professionals christian
fellowship
yale law christian fellowship yale
students for christ and yale uoc
tonight's event is not a debate we are
not here to see people win
lose or score points off of one another
veritas is latin for truth so we're here
tonight for a real discussion connecting
truth to our hardest questions and
deepest beliefs
we have asked our presenters to share
personally
ask honest questions of each other and
model a conversation that all of us can
continue this evening and
beyond our hope is that everyone in this
room would be challenged
for those of you here who identify as
christians we hope you would be
challenged by both of our presenters to
examine your faith with intellectual
honesty and rigor and to confront the
deep issues we'll be addressing tonight
for those of you who think christian
faith is mystifying or irrelevant or
disproven
we hope you will be challenged from
hearing from a christian intellectual
who can make a serious case for why
faith in jesus makes sense to them the
veritas planning team aims to create
events that are relevant
thought-provoking and engaging to people
of all backgrounds and beliefs and we
need your help with that
so
you should have received a 60-second
survey card and a pencil we've we've
provided
and i would just ask that you would take
15 seconds now to fill out the top half
of the front side i'm actually going to
go ahead and do that myself
we're
we'll only use your email address to
send you a link to an online feedback
site where you can share your thoughts
on tonight's forum uh we really want
your feedback so please do sign up for
that
we won't email you about anything else
unless you check one of the boxes at the
bottom
or unless you win the raffle for the new
ipad and we're emailing you to let you
know
after the conversation please fill out
the remaining sections of your survey
card both on the front and the back side
the ushers will collect them at the
doors for those of you watching around
the country and maybe even around the
world
thanks so much for tuning in but i'm
really sorry we're not going to be able
to get you these cards in time to fill
them out
one final order of business normally
this would be the point where i tell all
of you to turn your phones off and put
them away
but i'm actually not going to do that
we're going to do things a little bit
differently we actually encourage you to
text during the forum yes and
uh we encourage you to text your
question for our presenters to the
evening
to the number behind me yes it's right
there
during the q a we'll choose the best and
most popular questions and present them
to
our professors
all right
we are thrilled tonight to have
tonight's conversation between professor
james forman and dr andrea gillespie
moderated by dr elijah anderson
professor james forman is a clinical
professor of law here at yale law school
and teaches in the areas of criminal law
and criminal procedure with an academic
interest in the race and class dimension
of schools prisons and police professor
foreman is a graduate of the yale law
school after which he clerked for judge
william norris of on the ninth circuit
and justice sandra day o'connor on the
united states supreme court
he then worked as a public defender in
the district of columbia
before co-founding the maya angelou
public charter school
he taught at the law schools of michigan
georgetown and nyu before returning to
teach here at yale in 2011.
dr
andre gillespie is an associate
professor of political science at emory
university and is a graduate of the
university of virginia she received her
master of arts in african-american
studies and political science before
completing her doctoral philosophy and
political science here at yale so we are
very grateful to welcome her back to new
haven this evening
in 2005 dr gillespie was appointed to
the political science faculty at emory
and received an appointment to the
department of african american studies
in 2013.
she is the author of the new black
politician cory booker newark and
post-racial america and she focuses her
research on racial and ethnic politics
in the united states post-civil rights
african-american leadership and
inter-ethnic political competition
she is also director of the james weldon
johnson institute for the study of race
indifference
professor foreman brings his expertise
in the racial element of criminal law
and also his years of public service
both as a public defender and as
co-founder of a charter school
dr gillespie brings her knowledge of
african-american politi political
leadership and research on racial and
ethnic politics to bear as well as her
perspective as a christian
dr elijah anderson is the william k
landman jr professor of sociology here
at yale and will be serving as tonight's
moderator
dr anderson has published several works
exploring the nuances and complexities
of urban life including code of the
street decency
violence and the moral life of the inner
city and streetwise race class and
changes in an urban community he did his
undergrad in indiana followed by his
masters in sociology at the university
of chicago and a phd in sociology at
northwestern
he began his academic career at
swarthmore before joining the faculty at
the university of pennsylvania he came
here to yale in 2007 to join the faculty
of the department of sociology
he is one of the most foremost
urban ethnographers in the united states
and has studied race and ethnic
relations inequality in the sociology of
culture
we are privileged to have these three
people join us tonight for
this veritas forum
on a personal note i want to emphasize
that while we hope this particular
conversation to be very fruitful for all
of us this is merely one part in a much
larger conversation that extends from
debating the names of residential
colleges to how we approach the very
foundations of our criminal justice
system
i hope to see all of you at future
gatherings exploring other facets of
these issues and i encourage you not to
let this conversation begin or end here
tonight
again thank you all very much for coming
tonight and so please join me in giving
a very warm welcome to our speakers
well to begin with
good evening
good evening
slavery
established
the black body
at the very bottom
of the american racial order
justice
taney
in 1857 in the dred scott
decision said
black people have no rights
that white people are bound to respect
it's very important
slavery
and more particularly the iconic
plantation
established the black body at the bottom
of the american racial order
with emancipation
black people migrated to cities both
north and south
their reputations followed them
they trickled in
became concentrated
the concentrations became ghettos
and we had the birth
of the iconic ghetto
the iconic ghetto
the iconic ghetto
in our day and time
has become
even more profound
not only is it an important icon
it's also a very important source
of stereotype
prejudice
and discrimination
the black body moves about in the larger
society in the white space often times
with a deficit of credibility
not because of anything that is
peculiar to the black person in terms of
merit
morality
achievement what have you
the deficit has everything to do with
the fact that the black person is not
white
very important to understand
so we're dealing today
with a kind of symbolic racism
in addition to the structural racism
that we face every day as black people
here
today we have the biggest black middle
class in american history
but so often times these people of color
move about
with a deficit
of credibility their work has to do with
the fact that they must disabuse people
of the ocean
that the
that the ghetto stereotypes apply to
them
so they work
and work
and work
and they get beyond the deficit of
credibility
sometimes only to achieve provisional
status
status
this is the reality
it doesn't matter what
class
you are
how much money you got
what matters is the color of your skin
in a world that privileges white skin
and denigrates black skin
this is what we're dealing with
so the things that you see on the news
and social media about
the police
shooting black people and all that
this is what i'm talking about
but be advised
what's going on in these circumstances
is not peculiar to that kind of
relationship between
the police and black people
unfortunately
american institutions are in crisis
american institutions are in crisis
before we launch into some of the meaty
questions we have for this evening i
wanted to give the students
a chance to get to know
you both better
so audrey would you uh begin saying
something about your bio
so um i'd like to tell you a little bit
about my personal story as a christian
and then also my intellectual story
about how i
came to study race so um
i grew up in a christian family my
parents were raised nominally christian
and
when my when i was about six months old
my mother
um came to understand that it wasn't
just important to go to church
or to have a professed belief in god she
really wanted to understand what it was
like to have a personal relationship
with jesus christ and she came to
understand that christ had died for her
and wanted to have a relationship with
her and so she committed her life to
christ at that moment
and then taught my brother and me the
same things and when we were young
children she led us to accept christ as
our lord and savior when i tell that
story because i think everybody has to
make a personal decision about
about following jesus or following any
type of faith tradition you don't just
you're not just born into it they're
decisions that have to be made at
various points in your life and so for
me that decision came very early in life
and it was a decision that i've
recommitted to at various stages in my
life as i've grown older as i've
developed and understood a little bit
more about what faith is and what and
what following christ is
um
just to lay it out on the table i'm
african-american
um in case you didn't notice
i grew up in richmond virginia so
oh wonderful yes absolutely so actually
i'm from henrico county so i grew up
about 10 15 minutes away from the
confederate white house and you'd go to
doctor's appointments on monument avenue
so i certainly grew up seeing
confederate iconography
and it just kind of blended into the
background you just kind of get used to
it after a while
race was something that i probably tried
to run away from i didn't want to be
defined by it
and
i was very early targeted for you know
being smart and so sometimes that
separated me from
my classmates and my peers in ways that
could be helpful
but in ways that also kind of could be
very um
damaging not just in terms of being
teased but also in leading me to believe
that i was somehow exceptional and that
i was probably one of a handful of black
people who could um
operate and move in a space like this
and i soon became disabused of that
reality but one of the things that was
actually really helpful for me as a
college student was that i was
intellectually interested in questions
of race and african american history and
so as i started to go to school read
take classes
my classmates and my professors started
to challenge me to think about racial
issues so much so that i actually
changed my career focus so when i went
to college i
had intended to become a lawyer
specializing in international law i
dreamed of arguing cases before the
international court of justice
and after taking classes in
african-american history and racial and
ethnic politics my professors were
telling me that i should probably become
a professor and i listened and i did
research work for them and i finally
came to that conclusion
as well and so that's in part how i
ended up here
for graduate school and it was a
wonderful time and i see old friends
from graduate school in the audience and
so it's actually really great to be back
here
and james with your focus on law
sure same question to you okay
so first let me say i mean y'all
probably know this because you chose to
come out tonight but
in case you were somebody who was drawn
by the title of the forum or
or drawn by the organization that's
sponsoring the forum
i just want to make sure everybody knows
what
what intellectual treasures we have here
on the stage so
eli anderson
dr
elijah anderson is
somebody whose work
has influenced me and has influenced
generations of
not just sociologists his field but
anybody who thinks about questions of
civil rights questions of the black
condition
questions of relationships between
police and african-american communities
his work is foundational and
many of you likely know it already but
if you don't
please get to know it
because you will change you will be
changed by it
and
dr gillespie comes in this
tradition out of political science
not sociology but
her work including her book on
cory booker and
the
new black leadership is something that
really must be read and she has a new
book coming out i'm not i can't speak to
the new one i've read the book um
about booker and um it's a it's a
masterpiece so i hope that you all will
make it your business to to get to know
these works
in terms of my own
um background i guess in terms of uh
i guess you know us about law i mean
so i my parents met in the civil rights
movement in the early 1960s they were
both in an organization called snick the
student nonviolent coordinating
committee
and
my dad was the first executive secretary
of stick and my mom was what she used to
call
she wasn't in the leadership she was in
the follow ship is the way she described
it but
she
dropped out of college to join
snick she was a student at sarah
lawrence and
and she couldn't she is the way she
tells it she just couldn't
get up every day and have her world be
research papers and writing when
what she was seeing on television and
what she was hearing about from other
people that had been in the south was a
was a level of racial injustice
that she felt like needed to be
confronted personally so she left
college
and joined the northern friends of snick
and then eventually moved to atlanta
i say all of that to say that
in a lot of ways my commitment to civil
rights and racial justice issues through
law was almost you know unearned i mean
it was something that i was i was born
into my my parents split up when i was
about seven
and we lived in new york city at the
time with my mom
and
after a few years she came to me and my
little brother and she said we're going
to move to atlanta
and
if anybody
here is from new york
you don't tell a kid from new york city
that they're going to move anywhere
because if you're in new york city
you're in the center of the universe and
everywhere else's country and atlanta is
for sure for sure country
i mean that's just how it is and so
but my mom you know my my dad is
african-american my mom is white
she they raised us as black children
and as black boys to be black men and
her
view was
that
the world that she was in
and the world that had come to be
created for us
was a world in which we weren't seeing
the kind of black role models that she
wanted us to see
and
i know you're thinking well new york
like you know there's places you usually
she could have moved to harlem but
there's a there's a funny way in which
it's almost easier to just
pick a whole another city and and they
she knew atlanta from the civil rights
movement so she moved us uh down to
atlanta and her
point was that she wanted us to grow up
opening the newspaper every day
and back back then that's what people
did they opened the newspaper
and see
black people
in positions of authority
she did not want our only representation
of black people to be
degraded or downtrodden she wanted us to
see black people and people in positions
of power and she wanted us to go to
schools with black principals and black
teachers and a strong black community
um
and that
that influenced me very profoundly i'm
gonna i'm so that we can keep going i'm
gonna stop now but the one thing that
i'll say that relates to then my journey
into law
is when i graduated from high school
as wonderful as my community was
i went to one of those high schools
where
if you look in the yearbook of the
freshman class
and then you look at the the pictures of
the senior class
there's twice as many pictures in the
freshman class as in the senior class
and what happened to all of those people
along the way was
people dropped out
people got kicked out people got locked
up people got referred to alternative
schools
and so even at even when i left high
school
even at that stage i knew
that somehow some way i wanted to try to
make my life's work
be about
the half of the kids that i knew in in
eighth grade ninth grade who didn't walk
across the stage with us senior year
audra in studying black leadership over
the years
in what has been called post-racial
america
you know given the steady stream of
racial incidents that are all across the
social media
and all
what does that term mean to you
nothing and it never did
so
and i usually have to put this
disclaimer because i have a monograph
and an edited volume that have post
racial on the title and my usual
defenses my editors made me do it
because it was for marketing purposes to
sell books so you know people started to
proclaim that america was post-racial
when the obama campaign started to gain
momentum in 2008 and so i think people
got really excited about the prospect of
an african-american president and
breaking that glass ceiling might be
evidence of the fact that american
society had finally opened up and it did
open up in some ways but there are many
many ways that we now are acutely aware
of now in which it did not open up and
so we were very premature
collectively as a country when we were
proclaiming
the nation to be post-racial so you know
president obama's success
is wonderful it is something that should
be celebrated
it is symbolically important for the
entire nation and particularly for
african americans but one man's success
does not necessarily mean that we have
arrived racially i mean even before we
start talking about police shootings and
i know we'll spend a lot of time talking
about that today if we look at every
basic measure of socioeconomic status so
from income to wealth to life expectancy
to educational attainment and all of
these kinds of things blacks are still
behind
whites and this has been the case
usually in roughly the same proportion
for as long as anybody in this room has
been alive so um
and that's not to say that there hasn't
been progress because clearly there has
been progress otherwise i don't think
any of us could be sitting
up here on this stage but i think we
lulled ourselves into sort of
putting too much emphasis into the
importance of the election of the first
black president when we decided in south
carolina in 2008 that america was
post-racial or as they said after the
south carolina primary that race didn't
matter anymore it still does and i think
sadly we've all had this rude awakening
in the last year and a half of the ways
in which it's it's still important
well james is a lawyer
whose work is focused on prisons and
schools and
crime
what is it what does it mean what does
this mean to you what where are we today
as a society
can i just
say something about south carolina so i
was i was
i was teaching at georgetown
in 2000
and i was involved with a group group of
students called uh
um hoya law's
holy law for obama we had to we couldn't
call ourselves georgetown law for obama
because it was uh
because we couldn't have the georgetown
name associated with a political
campaign so it's hoya law for obama and
we all went down to the in the south
carolina primary
and there was a group of us
uh that were behind the stage when
behind you know that that that group
that's in the background behind the
candidate when they're giving their
speech
there's about six or seven students and
myself
and there was this as you know there's
hours of waiting before they give the
results and the candidate comes out and
people started chanting race doesn't
matter the level of and and now it's
like ridiculous right we laugh as some
of you all started to do
but it's almost hard to capture
this this sense this like moment this
like little moment of optimism
even among people who really understood
that
race mattered a lot there was this
moment
of the idea that
that
that a black i mean my father would not
have been and every black person you
talk to will tell you the same thing
either they'll say i could never imagine
they'll say my father my grandfather my
grandmother could never imagine the day
so there and now this was a group of
students they had taken critical race
theory with chuck lawrence and mario
matsuda so whenever they were so we were
shout they were people were chanting
race doesn't matter and then my students
would say except when it does race
doesn't matter except when it does race
doesn't
it's one of my favorite favorite moments
from that campaign
so so yeah south carolina and race
doesn't matter
um
i mean you know the question you asked
you know was was obvious you know was so
broad
um
and it's it we see it it playing out
we see the way that race plays out
across the legal system
it has its roots
back in slavery as you i think
appropriately
started us with
because i think the thing
the thing about slavery that
people don't still don't comprehend
is is the psychic
and psychological toll that it takes on
a nation
to organize yourself in such a way
that you would hold
a race of people in bondage
and expose them to unending
physical assaults
tear
children from parents
wantonly
what are the things that you have to
tell yourself as a nation
about those people
that you are doing that too you have to
create a set of myths
and that's why
i think every every myth that we see
today
every stereotype or every now you know
implicit bias
that you see today that about african
americans that they try to test on the
implicit association test or otherwise
they're all rooted in slavery
because you have to believe that a
people
are
lazy
to justify
beating them in that way to make them
work you have to believe that they don't
care about the from their parents
you have to believe that their bodies
can endure physical abuse without
suffering in the same way
to be able to inflict that children
to justify selling children away from
their parents you have to believe that
their bodies
can endure
physical
abuse without suffering in the same way
to be able to inflict that kind of abuse
on them you have to believe that they
are naturally dumb
in order to justify refusing to educate
them
these are the things that we as a nation
that america had to tell itself
for 250 years for longer
than we have not had slaves
we had slaves
so for that entire period of time we had
to tell ourselves those things as a
nation about a group of people and that
doesn't go away
those beliefs don't just vanish
with an emancipation proclamation or the
reconstruction amendments
so that's why
it's essential i think
that we start
with slavery
enshrined in law in the constitution yes
with the three-fifths clause yes with
the fugitive slave clause yes
but also
deeply embedded
in our psyches
in a way that
i think very few of us
including black people
want to really really come to terms with
because of how painful it is to really
face up to that
well this is a great segue into the
issue of anger
and i was i was struck as
probably many of you were
by the way
the survivors
in south carolina
of that church
shooting
we're so ready
to forgive
it's part of being christian
to forgive
dylan roof
for the murder of those innocent people
yeah
and i would ask
audra
i mean the anger
for a lot of people was palpable i mean
for sure
and um
i would ask you just to pose this
question um
how do you as a as an african-american
person
how do you how do you deal with that
i mean
what do you do how do you deal with that
anger
yeah i mean
charleston was a really gripping it for
me as it was probably for
many people
and i was shocked and stunned and
heartened by the forgiveness of
the victims families
i had the privilege of participating in
a pbs roundtable discussion
in charleston
after the shooting and one of the things
that i took away from that was i had the
chance to meet
victims family members and actually
people who were there at mother emanuel
of on the night of the shooting and so
one of the things that was very clear
that people wanted to make you know
crystal clear was that not everybody had
forgiven yet
um and that forgiveness was a process
and so
that allowed me to sort of think and
reflect about what what uh what
forgiveness means in this context
both as a political scientist and as a
christian and so
i was allowed to write an op-ed piece
which you can find on pbsnewshour.org
about forgiveness and what role
forgiveness plays on it so
um i happened to be i was in new jersey
when the shooting happened and then by
the end of the week i was in um north
carolina and i was in my hotel room and
for some strange reason
i got up on saturday morning and i had
on fox and friends weekend
so it's not my usual practice but you
know the lead story was the forgiveness
and there as a christian there's
something very powerful about
forgiveness um
we're taught that because christ forgave
us we have to forgive other people um
and that if we harbor bitterness if we
refuse to forgive people then that
actually will um short-circuit our
relationship with god so it's imperative
upon us to to forgive people and that
was evident in what the families did at
that arraignment and so i understood
that i completely respected it and i
hope because i i believe that dylann
roof is not beyond redemption
um i hope that he remembers what
happened there and i hope that god uses
that to to draw him back to himself to
really bring him to a place where he can
repent of what he's done while he's in
that jail cell for the rest of his life
because i think he's got what's coming
to him
with respect to that
but what really got me about watching
the news was the attaboys and the pats
on the back that everybody else took
because of the forgiveness of that
family and that irritated me to no end i
was actually deeply offended by what i
was watching people who
would likely claim to be my brothers and
sisters in christ it was yay jesus see
how superior we are and then there's
that part of
during the public morning
where people continually talked about
the fact how people forgave and there
was no rioting in south carolina so
they're making class distinctions
they're acting like what happened at
mother emanuel was the equivalent of
what happened to eric garner or what
happened to michael brown or what
happened to tamir rice um there was just
so much going on there that was just
deeply offensive and just overlooked the
other stuff so when it comes to
forgiveness there is personal
forgiveness and then there's societal
forgiveness and i think we are in
different places depending on our
position and so you know if somebody
personally aggresses against you
i think you can use the legal system and
you know do whatever you have to do to
sort of take care of the justice end but
you're personally responsible before god
for forgiving that person that's the
turning the other cheek part of it but
when things happen on a broad scale and
they're well publicized and we as a
society are implicated in it we're not
victims we have a responsibility to sit
and think about well
why did this happen and what can we do
to fix it and so nobody in south
carolina well i don't see nobody but it
seemed like in that discussion in the
immediate aftermath there really wasn't
a deep serious discussion about what
kind of societal influences led dylan
roof to believe that he was superior to
black people because of the color of his
skin and what led him to that trigger
hair moment where he decides it's a good
idea to go get a gun and decide to go up
in a church and shoot black people up
who was teaching him the things that
ended up on that website
what are we what can we do as a society
to make sure that we can prevent that
type of of behavior again in the future
and we didn't see that instead we saw
people being really self-congratulatory
that charleston didn't burn down
and we um it sped up the moment to
remove the confederate flag from the
state capitol which people have been
arguing to do for generations and if
that's all that comes out of this is
that that flag came down i mean i'm
happy that the flag is down but as i've
said before i've gotten very used to
seeing confederate flags in my life so
that's it if that's all we got from that
then we didn't learn and we're talking
about how we forgive the shooter or how
we're separating ourselves from dylann
roof and just thinking that he's
marginal and not really sort of figuring
out how he's us
then we have not we haven't done our
jobs and we haven't gotten to the root
cause of of the racial sickness that is
inherent to the story of america that
was just a band-aid on a gangrenous
wound and so you know my fear what i
mourn about what happened from
charleston is that we didn't learn
enough from it and that there will be
some other incident maybe not as heinous
as this one maybe it'll take on a very
different form where we're going to be
going over the same issues again because
we refuse to acknowledge the ways that
racial hierarchy still persists in this
country and the ways that we are all
implicated in acts like that in ways
where we shouldn't be just so we're
saying well we forgive and so let's move
on from that
james one of the issues raised by the
deaths of
michael brown and eric garner
and so many others is this intersection
between
conscious racism and structural racism
a part of which as i alluded to my
introductory remarks is symbolic
racism as it were
there's a certain proportion of the
american population that will be
explicitly
and consciously racist
in their approach
but there's a real problem of structural
racism where well-meaning people
just by virtue of operating within the
prevailing institutions
end up supporting oppressive
racist policies
how do you deal with anger
you experience when you see legally
supported structures
of racism
yeah it's
hard right i mean
yeah it's hard to deal with that anger i
think that
you know i guess i would put to another
kind of of bias or racism out on the
table in addition to the
the two that you talked about
i guess you know you talked about sort
of personal and then also structural and
then there's also um you know implicit
bias which i guess is a kind of a yet
another category or maybe connected one
one of the first two but
you know this way in which
you know there's so much research now
about
people's association when they
you know if they see an african-american
face and they make an association to oh
you know this person is more criminally
inclined or this person is not going to
work as hard or this person more likely
to be a drug dealer
and
you know our
just even our
kind of
assumptions about
sort of who people are you know based on
the color of their skin i mean there's a
there's a there's a house
a couple blocks away from my house
that i walk past every morning to school
i take my son to our neighborhood
elementary school and we walk by this
house and there's always these
um
these groups of guys that are standing
out behind the house they're like i
don't know 18 19 20 21
i don't bother anybody they're just kind
of standing around smoking cigarettes
white guys
and
i remember asking another parent we were
walking and she was like do you know you
know do you know who those people are
and i said i don't know because there's
like a new house you know this group
just moved in this house i said i don't
know and
she says oh i wonder if it's like a
like a a college fraternity or something
and i remember thinking
like okay like that's an interesting
like assumption to make that about what
this would be
so
it turns out
that what this house is is it's a step
down
a drug treatment
addiction program
so basically
if you go to
some some other parents did some
research who were just telling me about
this basically if you go to like
chote
or
deerfield
or somewhere else and you have money and
you get kicked out of a prep school
because of like too much
drug use and addiction
which i didn't go to a prep school but
my friends that did say that like you
have to have a lot of drug use to get
kicked out of a prep school for too much
drug use
but if you do
then and you have resources
then you this is the kind of place that
you go to
so and this is so important and it's so
connected to your point about you know
the ghetto and the iconic ghetto
these guys get to walk around in public
space
without any
association of being drug dealers
or addicts
now
and and i want them to have that liberty
i don't think that people should be
subject to stigma
based on
drug use or drug sales for that matter
but we have another
we have a
drug treatment
quote unquote we have a place
for people who don't have money
who use or sell drugs
oh a mile away
from where i
i live which is right over here and it's
a whaley avenue jail
and i work there now so if you're poor
and given other factors as we talked
about then disproportionately
african-american in new haven so if
you're poor and black
then
where you go
for this problem is the whaley avenue
jail and if you're wealthy
and i'll just say wealthy because i
think if you were upper middle class
african-american you could
get into this spot as well although none
all the people there were white
that's where you go you go to a really i
mean it's a nice it's a beautiful house
it's right on it's a right on whitney i
mean it looks like
uh
a grand
east rock mansion
that
fact
is a is a manifestation of
the biases
the implicit biases and the structural
racism
that we've been talking about
and it makes me angry
i have to control it because i'm taking
my son to school
but then on the way home after i've
dropped him off i can be mad
christianity and law
in america
both have a mixed history
when it comes to questions of race on
the one hand many church leaders and
self-professed
christians
were part of the machine of racism
and felt no tension
between their christian beliefs
and their ownership of slaves
or oppression of african americans
on the other hand the civil rights
movement in america followed
the abolitionist movement
in britain
by being strongly religiously motivated
by being a strongly religiously
motivated movement
led by convinced christians who saw
their campaign
for justice as inextricably
linked
to their faith in jesus
likewise law
has been a huge factor
both in supporting
and undoing racist systems
audra
where are we in now in terms of
religion's role
in promoting or undoing
racism
well
um you know i believe that jesus is
omniscient
omnipotent i'm the present
but as my mother says he has bad pr
um
it is still true
with respect to race
in the church you know i've been in
church and heard people question
president obama's citizenship
heard people make snide comments about
social welfare policy with their
designer clothes on i kind of been like
shut up i really don't really want to
listen to this
so you know as a church particularly in
the american church we have a long way
to go and so when i think about this
from a spiritual standpoint
sin is
us our attempt to do what we want to do
when we want how we want sometimes to
try to achieve good things but to do it
in our our own strength
and so i think christians like anybody
else in this country are often motivated
by their own
self-interest motivated by
their own sense of sort of cultural
superiority and if they don't surrender
that to christ then it manifests itself
in ways that are actually really ugly um
and that's over at the root of all sin
so if we think about greed and arrogance
and all of those kinds of things those
are often also wrapped up in in in
racism as well
and so i what i see
sometimes in the church is that people
have not surrendered that aspect of
their lives what's actually probably
more damaging and more troubling and
this is something and i'm preaching to
myself sometimes
when you are confronted with the bible
telling you that there's no respect of
person that there's neither june nor
greek male nor female slave nor free
that we
would like to figure out a way to take
our culture or our self-interest and
rationalize it as being spiritual in
some way and we do that for lots of
things in our lives so i could take out
racism and fill in the blank with some
other ways that we do this
um
and it manifests itself it manifests
itself in consumerism here in the united
states
there probably is a reason why
prosperity gospel sort of you know
really took root here um and some of my
friends i think of marla frederick at
harvard you know who can talk about
reasons why african americans might be
drawn to it but it takes root here
because we have a tendency in this
country to try to take our culture and
then put the little patina of jesus on
it and say that it's okay and we've done
that with race too and we still do it
and we're going to have to
do the hard work
sometimes the slow work and certainly
the painful work of disabusing ourselves
that that and and laying bear before
christ and allowing god to tell us about
ourselves and to submit and so you know
i think about the scripture where jesus
says if any man come after me let him
deny himself take up his cross and
follow me what that means is that you're
gonna get told you're wrong about some
stuff you're gonna get told you that
there are certain things that you can't
do that your motives are wrong and if
you're really going to have that vibrant
relationship that intimate relationship
with god you're either going to submit
on that stuff or you're going to double
down on my own self-interest and then
when you do that that's how we end up
with all of these isms
so
james
same question for you how today
is the law used or misused in the uh
in relation to racist systems
wow that's that's a big question i i
think
that
so one concern that i have with law
is so let me about
say something about legal education so
kind of lost school
which is that i feel that one of the
problems with how we train
lawyers
and and i think therefore a problem with
law because
how we train lawyers then has an impact
on the law that that is created by those
lawyers as lawyers and judges and
advocates and policy makers
one of the problems is that we don't
have enough conversations like this one
this
this what i see every year
is
200 new law students come to this place
and i saw it at the other schools that i
taught at as well
and they come
with
with
dreams
and passions
and
a heart connection
to why they are here
they come
full of the memories of
the people
who
struggled in many cases
sacrificed
worked two and three jobs in some cases
to get them here
and then we they arrive and we
organize our operations
as to strip all of that away
and
to kind of educate them in
i think an unduly narrow way that
is overly focused on this thing we call
thinking like a lawyer
well
the greatest lawyers the lawyers that
have
mobilized for change
are not people that
lost touch with their with their values
they're not people that lost that that
lost a connection to the deeper
life questions that
that we're trying to wrestle with here
um
you know when i think of
somebody like brian stevenson
he
is one of the nation's greatest
lawyers and greatest civil rights
lawyers in our history
because of
that
deep heart and soul connection that he
feels to a history to a tradition of
struggle
perhaps to a
religious community
but
whether it's
you know officially religious or not
it's deep and it's spiritual
and so
i
i think we need more of this
if we're to
make law be an instrument of change as
opposed to
an instrument of
stasis and
and
inequality
audra
what resources do you see
in the christian faith for overcoming
or transcending
racial and socioeconomic differences
and why have those resources not been
more effectively leveraged up to this
point
when most people
in america especially most
african-americans
would identify on some level
as christians
well i mean i think the reason why
christians haven't been effective in
dealing with race is because we're
disobedient and we've just allowed
ourselves to wallow in disobedience and
if we're going to move forward we're
going to have to get past that and
that's going to require repentance
that's going to require actually looking
in the mirror and taking a real hard
stock about what's there and about what
we're doing that's wrong and people
don't want to do that people get very
very defensive and it manifests itself
in conversations where
people don't want to confront structural
inequality at all
if you point it out people sit and argue
with you about why you're wrong
i have a story and i don't know if the
student was christian or not but it's
the attitude that i want to talk about
in their christians who have this
attitude
you know i teach african-american
politics so
within the first two weeks of class we
talk about the reasons why blacks would
have a completely different worldview
born out of their experience and so we
talk about certain differences so
one of the differences i'll point out
are wealth inequalities
and so i can point out income
inequalities where we'll see that blacks
make far less than whites do dollar per
dollar
and then if we point out wealth
inequalities and look at median wealth
we could see
how you know it was 1 6 before the crash
and it plummeted to 1 20th and 1 18 for
blacks and latinos after the stock
market crash
and i had a student literally raised his
hand in class and be like you made that
up and then in my evaluation later that
semester say she plays with data like in
order to convey a point and it's that
type of attitude that i'm unteachable
don't really want to consider sort of
alternative points of view that usually
lends to their being impasses and those
attitudes are prevalent outside of the
church and they're prevalent inside of
the church and so what that suggests is
that there's a certain hard
hard-heartedness there's a certain lack
of humility there's a certain arrogance
that god calls sin in any form and it's
just manifesting itself here so on a
spiritual standpoint what needs to
change there is grace
and a lot of us think about grace's
unmerited favor and mercy
but in the greek grace is really god
getting on the inside of you and
changing you and really empowering you
to become what he intended you to be in
the first place
and
that would require us to give up control
and we don't like to give up control
that's why we sin that's why
humanity is is in such a fallen state so
we're going to have to do that
and then figure out the ways to apply
that to this particular issue and so you
know i think the breakthrough comes when
people can actually sit down and have
honest conversations with one another
where people are being humble where
people are sitting and listening
particularly people who come from
privileged backgrounds and people are
privileged on many different dimensions
so i'm not just singling out certain
people
in this room but where people can get
past their privilege and actually listen
to other people's stories to listen to
different historical points of view to
take in different data and to understand
what people are talking about because
there are sometimes in this academic
struggle where you are sitting and
you're making certain points and people
will literally say and argue with you
about facts so we don't even have a
common ground on which to talk about
certain things
we're going to have to get past that
structurally
i wondered the extent to which in
christian communities even when people
are well-meaning and well-intentioned
whether or not people actually know the
historical context the social context
the economic context and so that leads
them to do things that are insensitive
even if they're in fact well-intentioned
and we're gonna have to get past that
and we're to have to start training
people to do better and to know more
before they start entering discussions
half cocked demanding to be in charge
and trying to make change that's
actually you know not sustainable or
actually not even appropriate or
welcomed
james what initiatives and law are being
taken
these days to address various forms
of systemic racism
what roadblocks
do these initiatives face
well i think
probably where some of the most
i think kind of activity that you see
right now
within the legal system
is is an area that
folks in the room are familiar with
because it's gotten more and more
media attention and otherwise but i
think that the
sort of mobilization against
the
having the
history's largest
penal system
the largest criminal justice system in
the history of any democracy
is
with all that then comes with that
because it's not just the prisons but
it's everything related to and around
that from probation to parole to
policing to collateral consequences to
can't get a job to can't get into public
housing to can't get a loan to go to
graduate school so all of that
i think is an area that
we've
right now is a moment of momentum it's a
moment and and with sort of
african-american leadership
at the grassroots from the black lives
matter movement to
to intellectually whether it's
you know people like yourself that have
been working on it for many decades to
more recently you know on this campus
people like vessel weaver
to african-american intellectuals in the
public sphere from you know tanahasi
coates to
brian stevenson to michelle alexander to
khalil muhammad you know this is a
this is a deeply
african-american-led and influenced both
intellectual movement and political
movement i don't think we should lose
sight of that
so
in terms of roadblocks
for me the biggest roadblock right now
to that movement
well there's many but
one
is i think that we
have unfortunately
in including led by president obama
have this focus on what we call
non-violent drug offenders and
non-violent drug offenders are the
people who we've now decided might
deserve a second chance might deserve
mercy
might deserve an opportunity to return
home earlier president obama in his
speech to the naacp went over and over
out of his way to say i'm talking about
non-violent drug offenders and then in
the press conference the next day he
said i don't have
much sympathy for folks who commit a
violent crime
that is a profound mistake it's a moral
failing
to take that position because
the
same
socioeconomic and cultural
factors the same oppression
that lead
somebody to decide that they're going to
commit what we're calling now a
non-violent drug crime
are also the same things that would
cause somebody to commit a crime that
we're now calling a violent crime and is
outside the scope of our care and
concern
it's also
a problem
because it's not going to solve our
it's not going to get us down from being
the world's largest jailer we've
we've advocates have contributed to this
have sort of sold this myth
that
if we got rid got the non-violent drug
offenders out of prison
that somehow we would solve our prison
crisis it's not true we could take every
non-violent drug offender out of
america's prisons today every single one
snap our fingers we would have the
largest prison system in the world still
so please understand that it doesn't
mean that the war on drugs is not worth
fighting it is
but it just means that you can't stop
there
so
and it's also
i think a moral
error and a moral failing
because
of the message it sends
to anybody right now who's sitting
behind
bars we've told you if you're there for
anything other than a non-violent drug
crime
you're you're not in any different
position than you were before this
movement to bring mercy into the
criminal justice system began
you are stuck there you are the other
you might as well be buried under the
prison for the rest of your life
and we cannot we cannot say that and
call ourselves racial justice advocates
and we cannot say that and call
ourselves
i think
moral people
we'll take the liberty of raising
another question
follow up
and see i think that with
this is kind of a rhetorical question
really but with so many black people in
in jail
in prison
and defined as dangerous and hostile and
criminal and all of that not to mention
people living in the ghetto
there's a sense in which
there's an implication that black people
are this way you see
and so as black people move about in the
larger society
especially the white space as it were
not only the deficit of credibility is
visited upon those people
until they can prove they're not
criminal
that they're not dangerous
that they're not immoral
see this is what we're dealing with
the ghetto itself
becomes a status defining place
you see
and it dogs all black people
especially those black people who move
about in the white space
you see
andrew and james racism is older than
america
and seems to be able to morph from one
form into another through the centuries
on a personal level
how do you keep from just giving up
trying to change
how do you how do you keep how do you
keep on
as it were
well
i think there are a couple of things one
there is progress to be made so if at
the beginning it sounded like i said
inequality it never kind of
hadn't improved there are some measures
on which it hasn't and there's
definitely progress
there are plenty of problems in 2015
they are not the problems of of 1965 and
so on the whole we you know are better
off and so i guess i agree with martin
luther king and president obama that the
uh
immoral arc of the universe is longing
to bends towards justice um so that
gives me hope i also think my faith
gives me a perspective about things so
when i think about jesus
and the fact that he knowingly came here
to die for people who didn't always care
about him or what he had to say
he also came with he wasn't jaundiced
towards people he was coming to save sin
sinners
and so
he had a certain expectation that people
were going to be flawed and he loved
them anyway that was why he came here
and so if christ could do that for me
knowing how flawed i am
then that gives me the opportunity and
the space to love people and then to
also not be disappointed when people
screw up
and to understand that that's going to
happen it doesn't excuse it doesn't mean
that i won't fight against it
doesn't mean that i don't have the
responsibility to use my voice to call
people out on those kinds of things but
there are also places where i
expect
failure i expect that there may be some
contention and so i don't get
disappointed and that might actually end
up being protective for me
um in many ways it's also helpful to
remember and i don't always remember my
life that i'm not fighting this battle
alone that's part of what the faith is
about is that christ fights for me
through me with me
so
that helps me to sustain myself and it
helps me to maintain a sense of optimism
i also think that
especially when it comes for rights
i would love to be able to change
everybody's mind about everything but
realistically speaking that's not going
to happen and so my goal in terms of
using my scholarship for justice work is
to not
i mean and i think they're people who do
this far better than i do in terms of
being explicitly justice focused in
their work but for my work
i will change the minds of the people
who are actually in a place where their
minds are willing to be molded and
changed in that way i know that there
are some people who are never
going to change their minds because of
anything i do are saying god bless them
i still have a responsibility to love
them but i'm not going to get
discouraged because somebody chose to be
calcified in their ignorance when i
could look at people who do care and who
are willing to learn and who are willing
to engage in dialogue and so i just
focus on on that
james
yeah i think for me
the
kind of the
the will to carry on comes is for me is
more
you know historically rooted so
i've been thinking a lot about this in
in the past year two years because you
know so many of my students
have come to me in alaska in such pain
and
and
you know one of our
one of the things that i one of my jobs
and one of the things that i treasure
about being a professor is
um
the role that i can try to play in in in
talking to them and
so
i've often thought about
a camera in this regard i've thought
about a conversation i had with my
father so
i was in law school
when
there was really the first
brutal police beating that was caught on
tape
and this was rodney king in los angeles
and
i was so
i was a third year here
when it happened
and i had already known that i wanted to
do something in the criminal justice
system i
started was thinking death penalty and i
eventually became a public defender
and when this happened it really it all
it immobilized me like i i actually
couldn't i basically dropped out of
school for
a number of days or almost a week i just
couldn't the notion that i would walk
back into this hallway and like sit in
the room with the same professor who was
exhibiting no understanding that this
had just happened or the pain that it
might have the toll that it was taking
and talk about some abstract thing i
mean it just it felt useless to me and i
went and i talked to my dad
and my dad had been beaten by the police
himself in the 1950s when he was a
student at usc he wrote about it in his
memoir and it was a story that he talked
about a lot
and
as we do with our parents i was kind of
using him to
express some of the rage that i was
feeling because it was safe to do that
and i was telling him in a way that i
normally never would
you know that it was pointless and why
had he been telling us that we could
make this difference and really what was
the use of the civil rights movement
anyway i mean if he was beaten like that
in 1950 something and now rodney king
was happening in 1992
what had changed in the same city in l.a
and
the normal move that he would make at
that time was what you said
dr gillespie in terms of talking about
what has changed you know and pointing
out to me all the areas you know that
was his normal
and it was a good response it was a true
response
um but
this day when i was talking to him he
didn't do that
this day
he
said to me
that i must have been
misunderstanding him all these years
because
he said that
he wasn't
he had not given his life
to the movement
he hadn't been jailed and beaten by
mississippi racist sheriffs for decades
because
he thought that he was going to change
america
in a year or in a decade or even in his
lifetime or even in my lifetime he said
no no no
we're fighting
for
tomorrow
and we're fighting for 10 000 years
from tomorrow
and that idea
that we're fighting for ten thousand
years from tomorrow
is
really at the root
of what kept him going this idea of the
struggle the meaning in the struggle
because of the struggle
and so for me
i often will tell myself the
look at how things have changed that's
my number one go-to when i get down
but on days when that doesn't work
like
that day in
charl in in charleston
that day when i have to go deeper
i go to that conversation
with my dad i go to that
the memory
and and he's passed now but the memory
of
the idea of him fighting for
ten thousand years from tomorrow
there's a there's a question as to how
these incidents reverberate through the
black community
not just the charleston shooting but
something going as far back as rodney
king
yeah
my mother lives in
l.a
and after the rodney king incident i
visited her
i said mom let me use your car
okay
be careful
i don't want no
rodney king
you see
in other words i was at risk
and she felt that
intensely
there's a sense in which
when we see eric garner when we see
michael brown and we see a lot of these
killings that go on
there's a sense in which people
internalize that yes black people young
black people yes
and become wary
become nervous identify become angry
then what do you do with the anger you
say
again that's just rhetorical
andrew you want to speak to the same
question so i mean in terms of how you
deal with the it's first of all i think
it's okay to be angry the bible says be
angry and sin not so there's a way to
just figure out how to
channel your anger in a way that's
productive and that's not
self-destructive
um
so
if you're angry i think you have a right
to be angry one of the things that helps
from a practical standpoint in terms of
dealing with that is to put this into
historical context and i think that
that's what has been so jarring about
the last year and a half
especially for millennials because i
think many people kind of believe that
race didn't matter in 2008
and then all of a sudden now
race matters to them in ways that they
hadn't bargained on and we're a little
bit older so we knew race mattered along
there was stuff we had seen or stuff
that our parents had heard and so the
farther i think we get away from the
second phase of the civil rights
movement in the 1960s where for people
this is really a distant memory
and this is stuff that their
grandparents went through and it's not
quite accessible to them i think it's
harder for them to grasp that what has
happened to them is not new to american
society and that there's there's
definitely something to be gained from
the experiences of other people and so
whether you gain it from talking to
people who lived through those
situations or by making sure that you're
properly educated about what happened it
at least gives you some context that
people have lived through this before
and then live to tell the story we know
not everybody made it through but the
testimonies of those who didn't
necessarily make it through are also
there
to be a lesson to be a comfort to be
encouragement to people i think it's
also important for people to have the
space to be able to do this in community
on my own campus when some students
talked about racial incidents that
happened to them i heard students make
comments like they really didn't know
who to talk to so they would kind of go
on twitter
and they were asking the wrong people in
my opinion about how to interpret these
situations and so
you know it's a shame if they don't
realize sort of who the community is for
them to go talk to to put things into
context um you know when people are on
campuses where they're not necessarily
critical masses of minority students
where people don't feel comfortable
talking to professors who will be
sympathetic whatever their rates are but
particularly faculty of color to help
them process those experiences you guys
have an amazing privilege of being in a
space where there are places where you
can go where there are people who are
designated to talk to you about these
issues and to help you process them so
we take advantage of what's here and
where it's not there when you are in
positions of power and you will soon be
in positions of power you go to yale
you know anytime they talk about people
in the news they always put your college
name in your year of graduation by the
next so you know i i don't even have to
look at the ydn i know ben carson's
college and graduation year right there
john kerry's
take advantage of that and make sure you
create those spaces where people can
kind of sit on top because the reality
of it is is that i go through stuff from
a racialized standpoint on my job and
there are people i can go talk to about
this who understand who've gone through
similar situations can provide advice
and can provide support and i'm not
quite sure that we have the same level
of social capital right now and i think
that's part of the reason why i think
the last year and a half in particular
has been really jarring for many people
it has really exposed the lack of social
capital yeah i mean there's a sense in
which
both of you
are change agents you see
and there's always the question
how can you keep
from giving up you know
there's always that question
where does the hope come in you see
see
andrew and james it's easy for us to say
that we want to see these changes at the
systemic level
but is there anything people in this
room tonight
can do
or could do to be a part
of the change
they want to see
well i'll start
like it or not y'all are the man so
actually you are in charge of the system
or you soon will be and so keep that in
mind um that this isn't just idle
chatter and talk for you guys you guys
have privilege
and
you're going to be called upon you could
either use that privilege for your own
um good or you could use it for the
betterment of other people
so it would be a question of how do we
think about this i think part of it is
just being mindful of how privilege
exercises itself
so if you can walk into certain spaces
around town and get treated better than
other people then you need to bring
other people along and point that out to
make sure that people get treated
equitably it could even be um you know
in simple stuff like you know especially
for somebody like me who's coming from a
minority group who's not always used to
being in positions of power you know
i've been in positions where
people have created
black organizations in an attempt to try
to integrate systems
and
when they get into positions of power to
do the exact same things as people did
who were oppressing them before and i
was like we weren't trying to break into
the old boys club to be the old boys we
were trying to smash this thing up so
remember that you're supposed to smash
the thing up like what those folks were
doing was wrong you're not trying to
join in their madness you're supposed to
change it
so you've got to kind of keep that in
mind and if it involves having people be
accountable to one another for you to
get called on the fact that you're
acting the same way that everybody else
did and it wasn't right when they did it
and it's no more right when you do it
then so be it i think it's also just
being mindful of the little ways in
which structure matters and in which
structure is not always pointed out as a
plausible explanation for why certain
things are wrong so that then we can
consider fixing it so you know i just
just wanted to ask the show of hounds
how many of you heard about the study
that came out of princeton it was widely
publicized in the past couple of days
about how mortality rates among 25 to 50
year old whites are increasing you heard
this story so okay
and it was actually really interesting
to watch the sort of narrative and the
report about the study oh my gosh white
people are dying more it's like black
people and latino people and native
american people been dying for years and
nobody seemed to care
so the fact that we're all up in arms
because white people are dying it's not
i don't want white people to die i just
want to be very
not trying to kill off white people but
the fact that we seem to be more alarmed
about this than we have about high
mortality rates in minority communities
is troubling and it was funny i was
watching the news last night listening
to a story where people were trying to
explain this higher incidence of
mortality has a lot to do with substance
abuse and it has a lot to do with
structural issues like people lost their
jobs
and they might be self-medicating
through this you know drug and alcohol
use so i was like wow all of a sudden
this is a structural issue to deal with
white mortality but when we point this
stuff out in black communities it's
black people's fault i was like well
there's something wrong with this
narrative i'm sure the people were
having this discussion were well-meaning
but this was a messed up conversation
where systematic systemic stuff is okay
when we're talking about white people
but it's not okay when we're talking
about black people we're gonna have to
call people out on that and sort of call
people on their hypocrisy about that and
not practice that type of hypocrisy and
then i just think on a personal level we
all have biases
and so sometimes we aren't aware of them
but sometimes they manifest themselves
through examples it could be through art
it could be through literature or it
could be through personal conversations
i think we have to be receptive to
people pointing out those biases so that
we don't act on them in a way that
actually hurts other people and gives us
unfair advantage compared to others
this is the last question to you both
james
where do you see the hope
what do you see the hope
where
where do you see the hope it's a heavy
issue
i want to answer that last question
about what it is that people can do
well let's let's let's stop let's go
let's go there then we'll come back to
this other one
i i think that
one thing that folks can do is i i feel
like especially in this moment when
i mean as somebody who's worked on
issues of mass incarceration and
police aggression
and disparities in the criminal justice
system for
really my whole career
i'm so thrilled that that
is now part of the national conversation
but there's one
the only
well i talked about the non-violent
thing earlier but the only kind of other
thing that that
that bothers me about it
is there's a way in which that
conversation
is so easy for people to put
outside of themselves
so
people can be obs people can say well
uh yes the you know i don't like that
the police shouldn't be doing that or
the judges shouldn't be doing that or
the criminal justice system shouldn't be
doing that and i think that and this is
connected to what you were just saying i
think that we also have to
not lose sight of
what our own role is and and how what
are the ways in which we are implicated
in ongoing
racial justice or racial injustice you
know i think about this
a lot you know here we are
on the yale campus
and
you know i have
you know i look at my own faculty here
at the law school
and when i was a student over 25 years
ago we had three african-american
professors on the faculty
and yale law school is the school that
prides itself on producing its graduates
are
those that go and become law professors
so we've now been
producing graduates for 25 years
since i graduated and today in 2015
yale law school
has exactly the same number of
african-americans on this faculty as it
did in 1990
and that's intolerable and so when if i
have a colleague that wants to talk
about police brutality i'm like yes i'm
for sure want to talk about that oh by
the way let's also talk about our own
systems
and the places we can control directly
not just ask the police department to
fix their systems and leaves our leave
ours untouched i think about it every
day here i am on the yale campus i walk
by
i live in a city
new haven connecticut that has
some of the nation's nation's highest
african-american unemployment
and i walk down prospect street every
morning
to
yale law school and on the way i pass a
an enormous construction site where
they're building two new residential
colleges
and there's hundreds
hundreds
of construction workers
in good jobs
building that dormitory
and there is hardly a black face to be
seen on the construction site
and i want to say if yale
wants to make an investment in new haven
or
you know if people
on yale want to talk about what they can
do
about racial injustice i want to say
well what about our own hiring practices
there's nobody in new haven there's
nobody
over right over here three blocks here
there's nobody that could work on the
construction site really nobody
and so
those are the kinds of things that
we it's so easy to just turn like to not
even see to just walk on and walk on
and and what i would ask everybody to do
is to look at your own life
to look at the institutions that you can
control where are the places where you
can have direct influence
what are the organizations
that you belong to
the
employer that you may may be able to
control or maybe that you are maybe you
are the employer
and ask yourself
what can i do directly in my life
to advance racial justice
so bring it close to home
it's a very powerful statement
because what you're saying is
true not just
not just with respect to
that construction site but
in restaurant after restaurant i go to
restaurants and i see all white people
serving me
yeah all white people
it's not just that but institution after
institution after institution
there's segregation
and this is not peculiar to new haven no
but it's bad here all over the country
yeah that's right that's right
i want to i want to raise this last
question although i think we've covered
so much
really
um
you know
when you see
so much of these
so many of these problems it's so easy
to see them as intractable
you know
i mean
as you say
you go by that construction site
i've been by then i've seen the same
thing oh yeah
i've seen the same thing your department
is right up the block right
and i walk around yale's campus and
there's a sense in which a lot of black
people see this as a white space as it
were
see
and so all these issues you can feel
hopeless you can feel that
this problem is intractable
and what do you do with that what do you
do with that
how do you how do you keep on keeping on
when you see that again and again all
over the place
you see
it's almost a rhetorical question i
think we've kind of spoken to this
really
so i think maybe we should begin to take
uh yeah i think
if you want to take that take it but if
you don't we can we can move on and uh
yeah no i'm ready to turn it over to i
think well first of all this was an
absolutely extraordinary conversation
so i recognize that it is now
five after nine and
some of you may need to be leaving
i'm going to take the liberty to take
about about 10 extra minutes to ask some
questions
but if you need to leave please please
please don't leave without filling out
your card
and
the rest of you can stay put for maybe
about 10 more minutes while we ask our
speakers a couple more questions
um so to both very quickly at yale in
the last few days many uh black students
have said they are exhausted with
educating white students about their
experience
will that ever change
no
probably not you just i mean yeah there
are certain things i i what i would love
to tell black students is you don't have
to bear the burden of being the
representative of all black people on
your shoulders so feel free to not have
to answer every question
all the time and what i would encourage
other people to do
is to also take it upon themselves to
necessarily be lazy in their learning so
not ask a minority sort of you know you
can take some agency you go to a
world-class school there are classes you
can take books you can read on your own
so that you can take the time to learn
things and so and to be able when you
ask questions to ask them in a way
that's respectful and empowering but you
know one of the things that i think some
of my own students struggle with on on
my campus is
when you feel that you're doing racial
justice you've got to cover everything
that's the beauty of having lots of
people with lots of different interests
and talents but you can specialize and
so i guarantee you don't have to be a
member of every minority student
organization or issue there are plenty
even on a campus where you know that
could be more diverse there are plenty
of people to go around to cover
everything so you know it's you know you
do have to
sort of
pace yourself a little bit and make sure
that you have boundaries and that you
know how to say no to certain things
and also and i really do believe the
answer is no in in in in that
in other words i think you're exactly
right that other folks
and we're talking about this in the kind
of race lens but you could apply it in
other dimensions right if you're
if you are the kind of the outsider to
that group that's oppressed at that
moment
um then you have to take it on yourself
to educate yourself but it's true that
if you are that group it's it's not
going to end i mean we see this you know
on the faculty level i mean
you know
black faculty faculty of color women
faculty women of color are always
disproportionately
on committees and we take on these
responsibilities because we feel an
obligation to
advance some of these issues but it
takes a you know it takes a hit on your
scholarship if you're serving on yet
that extra committee and so the question
of so the only other piece of advice
that i would give
is after recognizing that it isn't going
to change
is also know that though you step
forward and you step back and we work
and and we
we you have to work as a team so that's
why you do have to work in community i
was just emailing one of my colleagues
about
some you know issue around you know
diversity and
and and my colleague was like you know
i'm tired i am so tired
i'm glad
and you know we're like
we're grown right we're like in our 40s
we're like i'm tired and i emailed my
colleague back
um
and said
yeah i get it i'm i'm i'm on this now
and you take a break because that's what
we do we you know we take turns and you
rest up and then you'll get back in it
and my colleague will
uh and so that's the other thing we have
to be there for each other and be
willing to and be willing
my colleague needed to take the break at
that moment so you've got to also know
that you when you when that time comes
for you and you need to step back you
need to finish your paper you need to
study for that exam
give yourself that liberty
to step back do what you need to do
because
the fight will be there and it needs you
rested and ready
so
i have to apologize to all of you who
sent in some tremendously thoughtful
questions um in the interest of your
time and in your time i'm going to ask
you guys one more question
so the last question uh what's one short
thing you'd like to leave with the
audience professor foreman if you'd like
to go first
give one thing to leave them what would
it be
i would say love
and i say that
because i feel like like love is not a
concept that we talk enough about in law
school
and i don't think it's something we talk
enough about in even in the university
setting
when i when i started this alternative
school for kids in the juvenile justice
system
one of the things that we talked a lot
about
in our founding days and on our first
year was that we wanted to create an
atmosphere
that was grounded in a place of love
and school
administrators don't talk about like
love that really any more than than
lawyers do
and
but
that's what we were motivated that's
what brought had brought us to the work
and
so i think it was essential for us to
keep
talking about that talking about that
emotion what it meant and the way that
it could guide our work going forward so
so i would ask that that
that we not stop talking about love
um and this might be
directed toward the christians in the
room but
um
you know when it talks about
through us come uh rivers of living
water
that that's the sort of this notion that
we're not doing this alone we're
definitely not doing it on our strengths
if we do it in our own strength we are
going to get tired and we're going to
fall short and we're not going to
achieve our goals so i think you know a
big takeaway is to
do this is not an excuse faith without
works is dead so i'm not saying not to
be active
but to be active in a smart way knowing
that god has paved the way before us
that god has given us the tools to be
able to embark on this quest for justice
in a way that's meaningful and that god
in the end is the one that that is going
to do the work and do the work through
us if we avail ourselves of that
opportunity
thank you very much and if you guys
would join me in giving thanks once
again
thank you
thank you
and thank you very much to you guys for
coming if you would please sit down and
not leave just yet
i do have a few short announcements um
the first
uh very short i promise this is gonna be
short um
you have this survey card please take
that out
and while i'm talking at you for the
next minute and a half please please
fill it out the ushers will collect them
at the door the sociologists and me
would like to emphasize that your
response rate is very important to us
uh first immediately following this we
are hosting roundtable discussions in
the dining room of the year of the hall
of graduate studies on the other side of
york street
uh it's an opportunity to gather with a
few others and facilitated conversations
about
your responses to what's been shared
tonight
there will be light refreshments
available available there
several of you have already signed up
online to participate in that but
there's plenty of room so please don't
hesitate to go
if you want to
speak with the professors they may be
here afterwards for a few minutes please
feel free to come up um alternatively
don't hesitate to raise those
conversations at the reception
secondly if you enjoyed tonight and want
to be involved in planning these sorts
of things please check the appropriate
box on that card you're filling out
and we'll contact you the veritas forum
is a national organization and hosts
events all over the united states
particularly in the northeast we have
upcoming forums at harvard medical
school penn and
columbia hope you guys have enjoyed this
conversation i know that i have and i
think it's been extraordinary to have
dr gillespie and professor forman and of
course dr anderson moderating this so
thank you very much once again and again
we look forward to continuing this
conversation in other ways in the coming
days and weeks months and course years
thank you and have a wonderful night
thank you